will start you with Micah
Parsons. That was one thing
that stood out from football
night in America. As you said
right now, he's your Defensive
Player of the Year, granted.
That was before Monday Night
Football. What is it? That's
separating him in your eyes.
Listen, he's a rookie
and when you come in as a
rookie, your head is spinning
around. Write your first of all,
he's the first round,
draft choice. So, he's trying to
come in and trying to
establish himself in the locker
room and in all of a sudden.
The first week, we were there in
Tampa Bay. What do they do?
They throw them at linebacker?
They threw him at defensive
end. He is a rookie and he's
trying to come in and learn one
position and do it. Extremely
well on a high level, but now
they have them learning,
multiple positions outside
linebacker inside linebacker
defensive end. He's in the a
gap. Mugging.
Dropping back, 30 40 yards in
coverage. I mean what other
player in the National Football
League is doing what he's
doing? And that's all I'm
saying. I've said in Sunday
night, but no one's and this kid
is only getting better.
Just think about the more reps.
He's getting he's beating
people Nach natural athleticism.
He runs a for
three Emmy and two hundred
thirty five forty pounds man.
This dude is an absolute animal.
You cannot tell.
I don't care about Aaron. Donald
Matthew Jude on, he's been
one of the best but at the end.
End of the day.
This is my defensive player
right now. Now people are
starting to compare him to
Lawrence Taylor. I don't,
I don't, I'm not going to go
there. Lawrence, Taylor was
just something different, but
this kid is absolutely special.
He's humble. And he wants to
continue to get better.
Yeah, I don't think you can go
there yet. I appreciate you
pumping the brakes on that. But
I'm with you and it's not only
right now. It's not only
currently in the NFL. Nobody's
doing what he's doing. I'm
thinking back a decade. I'm
thinking back a
couple of decades.
I can't think of another name
who can play this many
different positions and play all
them so effectively. And
what he does, most impressively
in my eyes is that he closes
the Gap so fast. And how many
times do you see
a quarterback staying in there?
And Parsons has a free Rush?
Adam and before he can even make
a decision whether or not
he wants to Jus come out or
Throw it away, or throw it to
some receiver.
He's getting hit. He closes the
Gap without 439 speed, and it's
problematic. So he's 10th right
now in pressures, even though
he doesn't Rush nearly as often
as most of these pass rushers
Fifth and quarterback hits
seventh and sacks. He's got 12
to his name.
And this may be the most
impressive thing that I saw
25.2% win rate as a pass rusher.
So over a quarter of
his snaps when he's rushing he
wins and that's what it looks
like when you're watching a play
football. It's just pure
shear.
That's who else would be in that
conversation with you
Matthew
around for a while. To go ahead.
What you got. Hold on.
Think about the impact on his
teammates. Because
when you come in, as a young
player,
you have an impact and guys are
raising their level of play
guys are flying around, you
know, guys are getting better
because of Michael Parsons
because they see his level of
preparation and think about this
too, Dan,
when you're playing linebacker,
when you're playing defense to
end, when you're playing all
over the field, you got to be
smart. You got to be smart, you
got Be able to know all
the checks, all the adjustments,
all the games. If he's playing
defense
in, if it's an e.t. In tackles
stunt, he has to know that. So
he has to know, multiple
positions and all
the intricacies of that. It's
very difficult to do and man and
think about this to all
fensively. If you're
an offense, you look and you're
trying to identify well is
number 11. Is he the mic or is
he the outside linebacker? Or is
he playing defensive end
because he's moving all over the
place. So it
only Causes Chaos and confusion
to the offense. It's very
difficult to deal with when you
got a guy like him.
It is and you don't see any of
the others pass rushers making
as many tackles as he is. That
was the other thing. I was
looking at their own like the
20s or the 30s, maybe the 40s
high-end. He is 75 tackles this
year. So that
points to his versatility 17,
tackles for loss. The only guy
I saw above him on that list was
Nick. Rosa, sweet. S
the entire group, they're in
three forced fumbles. So he's
just
one of those players that just
creates Havoc no matter where
you put them. He is a
Havoc Creator. And I got to say
I am right there with you
as it currently. Lee stands
defensive player of the year.
Although Aaron Donald made
a heck of a case last night with
those three sacks. Go ahead
route.
I want I want to ask you a
question because I know
everyone's pumping, Tom Brady up
and deservedly. So but do
you think we can actually slide
a defensive player over there
and that conversation and could
he
potentially be mentioned as the
MVP of this league? Because to
me, I think what we're seeing
from Tom Brady, we're kind of
used to sin
but for him to be a rookie and
as bad
Das Dallas defense was last
year's poorly as they played as
inconsistent inconsistent as
they played. This guy
single-handedly comes in here
and he just changes the whole
tone of this defense. So I'm
almost thinking that this kid is
playing so well, depending
on how he finishes out. I think
he's going to finish how great
I think you can put them in that
category as possible in
vp2 right under Brady.
I'm with you. It's all a matter
of perspective there because
which once you put the word
value in because then it gets
down to positional value at
least in my opinion in
the quarterback position is so
much more valuable than any
other
position on the field.
I mean quantifiably so
that I don't know if I can make
that full push to put them over
the top of a Brady or some of
these other great quarterbacks.
We've seen even Aaron Rodgers
playing at an MVP level here
lately. I don't know if he's
more valuable,
but in terms of what he's done
this year, I think he's
a perfect fit for It's a Player
of the Year. Let's go to your
second on your top five,
takeaways here Rod, which is
defense and I think this is
really a cool Point by you as
these defense has sort of
develop on the Fly
throughout the course of the
season. That's what we've seen,
who were some of these
Championship defenses as we're
now through 14 weeks.
Well, I have them written down
and I'm going to start with
the Chiefs. I just think the
Chiefs they got to a point where
they
had so much success. Their
offense was so good. They got
lazy. They took their offense
for granted yet. It had some,
they had some injuries.
But Chris Jones, he has come in
and Melvin Ingram.
They've just absolutely just
changed his defense. When
you're getting pressure from the
exterior from the outside
and the interior, and now you're
forcing turnovers Tyrann
Mathieu. He's been making plays.
And we saw this, we saw this.
Group a couple times this year.
They're starting to fly around
they're starting to trust each
other and William gave middle
linebacker. His speed has been
just awesome from sideline to
sideline.
It is that you're starting to
see all the pieces come
together at once. I mean, I was
looking at what this secondary
has been doing one Thornhill
really been playing. Well,
Tyrann Mathieu. We just talked
to him. He's the leader, right?
He's the vocal leader. That's
passing all this knowledge
down to the rest of the guys.
Mike Hughes has really been
having a good year
in terms of Arias. Ward. Is
there other quarterback who's
been playing? Well, then you go
to their nickel, Richard
Fenton. He's the third highest
graded, Nick offender in
the entire NFL. So how many
defense is, can you look at
that? Have
three premiere pass rushers?
In five, very capable
very well. You're very, you
know, playing very well at
the defensive backfield. That's
a great combination linebackers.
Not exactly the most valuable.
If you can crush up front with
the pass rush and the back end.
That's how you play some really
dangerous defensive football
and a couple more teams that I'm
very familiar with at least
the, you know, the coaches.
I will go with New England
and Matthew Jude on and you said
this best.
And I remember you saying this
on Sunday and I thought this
I didn't really didn't hear
this. He is the best free. Of
the year,
he's the best free agent. Best
free agent pickup of the year.
I just think that he's been
outstanding up. Matthew Jude on
definitely deserves to be in
that conversation. Also, you
look at the Tennessee Titans
and their defense has to be good
because Ryan Tannehill is
up and down and consistent. They
don't have Derrick Henry
there to study wide receivers.
They're constantly injured, so
you don't know what you're going
to get.
So Ryan Tannehill needs to be
able to depend on that defense
to help carrying them. But also,
this is my last one.
Green Bay Packers, I couldn't be
more impressed with
the Green Bay, Packers, their
special teams. They need some
work. But Joe Barry came
in. He simplified the defense.
He says, look, I don't want to
give up. Big plays Miss
communication errors. We're
going to simplify to defense.
We're going to let our
defensive ends with Shawn Geary
defensive tackle Kenny Clarke
Devon Drake Campbell that front
seven
go take over and they've been
phenomenal. I mean Devon
Driggers Campbell, he's coming.
He's stabilized that defense.
He's been awesome form and he's
on a only on a one-year deal.
He's gonna Gonna get paid. What
about their secondary Jack?
I know you like this secondary.
That's a gratzer. Great. Great
Point, rasul Douglas, NFC
defensive player of the year,
right? He's the first one
that's done that since Woodson
since Charles Woodson. So
the week of the week, a key part
of the week
of the week of the week of the
year. Listen, it might as well
be at the year with the pick-6
and stacking up at this point.
And then you get Jai here,
Alexander back, imagine that
when he comes back for this
team, za'darius Smith comes
back
about David, bakhtiari comes
back to help. Sure up the
Upside. We all Proline.
This is going to be a
championship looking football
team, isn't it? I know we got
one with the bucks, but look at
the NFC. It's the same two
teams, Green Bay and Tampa.
They're coming together at the
right time.
No question. And if they're
getting healthy, but the big
question goes back to Aaron
Rodgers big toe, he comes out.
He says, oh, the big toe is not
going to be a problem. But then
yesterday, he talked about or
the day before he talked about
yesterday
house or it was it's going to be
so you never know
with these curved told.
And things like that, but
basically their success on
offense, is going to come down
to how healthy Aaron Rodgers
field.
Well, I could talk defensive
football all day. We got to
spin it back to offense for your
third takeaway from this
Sunday, which is Josh Allen, you
get watch that game and
we've been watching it really
throughout the course of this
whole season man to ask him to
do a lot. How much is
too much there for Josh Allen
though, Ron?
Yeah, I mean I watch the game
and he's he's he's absolutely
fantastic. When you see this
kid, the heart and just how
tough he is and type of hits
that he takes and type of
coverages and the blitz for in
the blitzes and all
the different packages.
But man, this dude is tough as
Nails. He said, look
forget about everything else.
You're not going to run our
running back. I'm gonna take
over. I'm going to take over
this game. Dawson Knox. He's
been a huge Plus for these guys
coming back. Big Target with
soft hands, but Josh Allen is
that do.
Man and Gabriel Davis, he's
coming along. I think they need
to give the ball to Gabriel
Davis more man. When I was out,
he's a big dude. He's got he's
got really good hands and he
loves playing football. So
they need to get back to running
the football. I don't
know what's going on with Brian
De bar know, you have this
third quarterback, but you got
to take some pressure, pressure
off and alleviate some of that
pressure and run the football.
At least, try to run a football.
It's a great point and they
don't have many awesome
options. He's out of the
backfield at running back at
some point that we've covered.
But if you look at the first
half of that game
here was their entire running
attack, right? It was Josh
Allen.
Four attempts, 43 yards in the
first half, not a single
receiver, or running back, how
to carry. So it was just Josh
Allen and when I look at
de-ball, this was an okay plan
for the big games, right? For
the big playoff game, for
the must-have game to get into
the playoffs.
Maybe at the end of the year,
maybe for the Super Bowl plan,
but you can't take Josh Allen
and make him your number one
running option for
18-week season and then expect
them to get you to the Super
Bowl. On top of that. It can't
be one design run after
another. He's already going to
do enough. Extending plays
scrambling making plays on his
own. You can't design all these
plays and have them get all
these extra hits already. Look
at a guy
like Lamar Jackson.
He's beat up when the Ravens
need him for a playoff push.
I just feel like it's way too,
risky of a strategy so I don't
care. If you need to grab a free
agent, running back. If
you like one of the guys on your
practice squad or on your
active roster, you have to start
handing them.
I'm the football or else Josh
island is not going to make it
for the long haul with how
talented, how great that he
really is
two things that keeps you keeps
you really actually keeps you
from going far in the playoffs
their inability to run
the football and an inability to
stop so and running a football.
And those are the two issues
that buffalo. Have you think
about what teams are doing?
They're coming in. They're
saying, look, I'm not worried
about you. You saw,
you got great quarterback, but
you're you are solved team.
We're going to run the ball down
your throat. The New
England Patriots. That was a
flat-out embarrassment. That's
why Sean McDermott.
I was so upset because he knew
that he got embarrassed on
National Television. So you got
to be able to stop the run and
you have to be able to run the
football
to really show how tough you
are.
And it was a really impressive
come-from-behind performance by
Josh Audi, get them back into
this game ultimately to get
this game into overtime. But
when you watch the game play
out - was a substantial lead
going into halftime the Bucks
Head. It was a substantial lead
even going into the fourth
quarter they had. So it took
Miracle plays to get them back
in it. But in reality, I think
Tampa's a better team than they
showed against Buffalo
specifically in that second
half.
It was pretty cool to watch. Tom
Brady, go 5, wide, and
spread it out. And then before,
you know it, he's got four net
in there and it's the Running
game. It's just the multitude
of different ways that their
offense can attack you
and then defensively,
I thought they did a better job
than anybody I've seen
particularly in the first half
of getting multiple guys
around. Josh Alan. If you just
get one or two, he can make
defensive ends. Messy can stiff
arm guys, and break tackles,
but when you get three
or four guys around him, like,
they were doing, you can get
some really big hits and on Josh
Allen. And that seem to be
affecting my thought Todd
Bowles. Really did a great job
in the first half. Yet fell
apart a little bit in
the second
half. But Todd Bowles,
very creative with those.
Usher's in the first half and
they were getting home.
Yeah, and also what he's dealing
with is he's dealing
with defenses that are kind of
plan like they're playing
Patrick Mahomes too deep. So the
one thing I would say about
Josh Allen if he can exercise a
level of patience when he sees
those two deep
safeties and he can just stay
patient and Nick and neck right
down the field. Incan don't
write down the field. Then what
happens is
people get tired of that is so
you know, what? We're tired of
that coach. It's like can we
place a man? Can we play some
3D and then all of a sudden you
get those?
Opportunities man-to-man
coverage. Now you can take your
shots down the field. But Josh
the biggest thing for him is he
has to just show a level of
patience, check the ball now
and just truly take what the
defense gives them. That's what
he needs to do. It's a cliche,
but it's the truth.
Let's Bend you to your fourth.
Take away, will keep it with
the quarterbacks will keep it
with some of the best offenses
and it's Green Bay. We just came
back from Green Bay for
Sunday Night Football. The Bears
gave them a little
tougher. Game, little tougher
test, that maybe we were
thinking going into, it really
got out of the
gates. Well did Chicago. But I
want to focus on the head coach
Wright and Matt LaFleur,
because they have won a whole
bunch of football games with
him there in town. He flies a
little under that A-Rod radar.
I understand that but how
valuable really is you and your
mind's eye there. Ron.
You know what? I think. I think
the one thing that I see from
him
and I see that calming presence.
I mean, think about,
I mean, to be able to deal with
Aaron Rodgers on a every single
day basis. All right, dealing
with him. In the meetings,
in the locker room,
you're dealing with such a
unique personality and such a,
like a such a special person and
he has, he has what it
takes. He has the demeanor, he's
calm. He's patient. He's
open-minded,
and the fact that he's got a JD.
And and Aaron Jones rotating
keeping those guys fresh and
healthy. I think he's done a
great job. His patience level,
just everything that
he's done.
I mean you got almost put him in
the coach of the year
situation because I mean, he's
dealing. He dealt with so much
and he's keeping everything
under control props to Matt. Le
Flore, man. He's doing a great
job.
It's a really good point, Cause
you never really gets a ton of
credit, whenever everything is
going great. Aaron Rodgers gets
the credit, but when things are
going bad, he's quick to get
the blame, right? I mean, so he
comes in
year one and everybody's going
LaFleur. He's too young. You
can't make him the head coach
13, and 3 goes straight to
the conference Championship
game, and then they draft Jordan
love,
and then you got Rogers going,
you know, four fingers deep on
the whiskey there, right? So
then you take off Aaron
Rodgers. They come back the very
next year. It's
a motivated A-Rod. He goes to
win the MVP.
13 and three Conference
Championship game again, then
this year.
You don't even know if Aaron
Rodgers going to show up.
I mean, you have the whole
offseason where he's in Hawaii
and you don't know he's at
asking for a trade. Who
the heck knows if he's even
going to be the quarterback.
Look where they are. 10 and 3
number one seed right now in the
NFC, just overtook
the Cardinals. So, I think you
have to give some credit to
LaFleur and I think he'd be
getting a ton of credit if he
had just been able to clear that
last hurdle, but that's
what the whole entire thing
comes down to, now, for
the Packers.
And they have been circling
for years now, a trip to the
Super Bowl again for Aaron
Rodgers. And they just have to
clear, most likely the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers potentially the
Rams
in order to get back to the
Super Bowl.
Yeah, think about what matloff
or did stepping up changing
defensive coordinators, Joe
Barry and give it and really
giving them stability on a
defensive side of the ball
because last year their defense
was so inconsistent giving up
big plays,
you know, broken coverages. It
was just a mess and when he's
come in, he's really solidified.
This defense. And
this defense is a defense that
can actually carry and help
carry the offense. There's going
to be times of Rogers,
not feeling well,
where maybe the offense is
stagnant, like it. When we were
out there early on and then all
of a sudden now, the defense
can create a turnover, they can
get
a couple stops. And that's what
you need. You need guys, like
rasul Douglas Adrian. A most
those guys creating turnovers
and making big plays.
Right? And he hires the
defensive coordinator and
that's works. You have to give
more credit for LaFleur there,
right? I really like your point
to. He does a good job of
balancing a rods ego and a-rod's
knowledge that he's acquired,
which is so much right. He
knows way more than your average
Quarterback, but he's
given all of that a little bit
of structure. And I think
that's, that's a delicate
balance. And that's an art
form.
So his ability to do that is
pretty darn impressive. Let's
get to your fifth. Take away.
It's a team that really doesn't
have a quarterback and really
doesn't have A solution at
quarterback. Moving forward, at
least doesn't appear that way.
But camaras back, for the
Saints.
What does he bring? Most?
May he's bringing a sense of
urgency man. He's playing with
that energy. He's their best
playmaker and he was
outstanding, whether it's
running a ball in between
the tackles are really what he
does. Best is catching the ball
out of the backfield
and everybody they might have to
utilize him a lot more in
the passing game when they plant
against Tampa Bay coming
up this week, this Sunday night.
So
but I like what Evelyn Kamara
has been doing them. I mean,
obviously, he's been hurt. He
looked like he's fresh. He's
got fresh legs. So we'll see if
it can continue because he
hasn't met a defense like this
recently.
That he's going to see like,
Tampa Bay.
That's right. Missed four weeks
with knee and hamstring issues.
Let's take a look at the numbers
so quickly. What
the Saints have been doing. So
this is with taysom Hill and
with
Alvin Kamara, to look at those
touches right there for Kamara.
Taysom Hill, right? Taysom Hill
is not going to be somebody
like Brady, who's going
to drop back and beat you with
30 pass attempts to game.
So he's going to need a chimera
type. We can just dump the ball
down to who's gonna need a
strong running game. If they're
gonna have any chance I they are
going to have a serious
headache on their hands.
Heading into Tampa with the team
is going to be ticked off.
They just let the Buffalo Bills
back into that game. Late to go
into overtime.
Yeah, you better expect, you
know, the game plan from Todd
Bowles is he's going to load
that box. He's going to make
sure that they don't get off.
So, you know, running
the football and they're going
to try to make taysom Hill, beat
him, make him one-dimensional
tight, man-to-man coverage,
forced taste them healed, or
throwing those type Windows.
That's what you want to do. And
I tell you, when he's running
around, he's gonna get a big
Taste of Levante David, you
know, Devon white. Those guys,
man. They they fly around.
They're big, they're thick,
just like him. I can't wait to
see it.
But he's taysom Hill is going to
have to drop back and make
some And passes, he can't just
run his way to a victory
against the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers.